i can see your voice is
the new show obviously the masked singer
is like the juggernaut of all
juggernauts and
i can see your voice has a very
interesting concept
can you explain it to us i can see your
voice is really trying to say
you know is a singer a quote unquote
good or a bad singer
they're all good people and they're all
good singers you know in in
in you know in the scheme of life but
you're just talking to see who's like a
professional singer
and who's not through a variety of clues
without ever hearing their voice
uh through lip syncing through q a and
just other
visual clues and their voice being
altered you find out if they're
professional singers and in my mind this
whole show is designed to help someone
win
a hundred thousand dollars uh have their
dreams come true
and have a lot of fun at the same time
with a bunch of uh celebrity friends so
it's a it's a lot of fun and it's a
great companion show to
uh to the mass singer if it's okay we
want to flip the script on you with our
own version called i can hear your face
um okay here's how it works we've got
four of our amazing team
who work on the show four different
people and they're gonna play
an audio clip of one of them singing a
christmas classic
and we thought maybe you could tell us
whose face
you hear is it chelsea our
writer and occasional murder hornet
sometimes she comes on the show as
murder hornet
um is it greta our fantastic
show runners assistant felicia
our digital maven the one
the only and marina our associate
producer extraordinaire
okay ready yes all right let's hear it
jingle bells jingle all the way
oh what fun it is
[Music]
oh my goodness wow what an
amazing voice first of all just shout
out
and props um oh my goodness
and everyone swayed uh
you know swayed professionally so um
when i take multiple choice tests back
in med school although you know
maybe it's either going to be second or
third so
felicia or greta okay any meaning emo uh
this is
this is how a doctor like you know
amazing greta amazing thank you so much
thank you so much for playing everybody
that was so fun
give it up for greta
[Applause]
and ken jong and be sure to check out
the season finale of i can see your
voice
tomorrow night on fox it's going to be
huge
as is new year's eve ken thank you
so much thank you so much for having me
you